at the sedan now where millions of
people have been caught in a bitter
power struggle between two warring
generals for over a month hospitals have
been destroyed and there's little food
water medicine or any basic facilities
for those trapped in the conflict
between the Army and the paramilitary
rapid support forces the two sides are
continuing to fight in and around the
capital Khartoum despite indirect talks
for a humanitarian ceasefire happening
in Jeddah Saudi Arabia and neither side
seems willing to back down freudia Carr
reports
thank you
Sudan's Army Chief Abdul fatah al-brahan
inspecting troops at the headquarters in
cartoon
[Music]
it's a rare public appearance for the
general his third since fighting between
the Army and paramilitary Rapid support
forces began in mid-april the battle for
control of Sudan shows no sign of ending
[Applause]
on Wednesday Army supporters
demonstrated in Port Sudan they are
demanding United Nations Envoy Volker
Perth as leave accusing him of
interference
we demand that volcker the UNM boy be
removed from his position he is
responsible for the conflict because he
has contributed to the division and
separation of the people in this country
both the Army and Rapid support forces
have claimed control of strategic sites
in cartoon this week
[Music]
and both insist they have the upper hand
the two have been holding indirect talks
in Jeddah since the beginning of the
month but they fail to agree on a
permanent resolution a series of
ceasefires have failed
burhan gives a statement that the truce
will be from this hour to that hour the
continued Air Raids and artillery fire
is proof that there is more than one
decision maker in this crisis and it's
one of the reasons that the hostilities
don't end it proves the lack of Will
from the Sudanese Army
and for Sudanese more stalled
negotiations means more uncertainty and
more hardship and suffering people are
leaving cartoon because there's no food
no water no electricity and there is
very high levels of insecurity wfp is
providing hot meals wfp will continue to
support refugees as and when they arrive
but the future is very Bleak for those
people it is Bleak for Sudan and it is
Bleak for the region
more than a month into the conflict the
UN says one million people have been
displaced they can't go home until the
two sides agree to stop fighting Freddie
a car Al Jazeera
well Sudan's two rival generals have
been jostling for control so let's take
a look at their military strength and
where that stands at the moment the
Sudanese Army has more than 200 000
soldiers and significant air power while
there's no confirmed information on the
number of Rapid support forces rsf it's
estimated to have around a hundred
thousand Fighters and at least ten
thousand anti-aircraft vehicles and
external forces are also believed to be
involved so there's Libyan warlord
Khalifa haftar and Russia's mercenary
Wagner group they've both been accused
of supporting the rapid support forces
on the other side of this Egypt is close
to the Sudanese Army and is reportedly
providing support to that side but the
warring sides both deny receiving any
foreign support Also earlier this week
Army Chief Abdel fatal burhan froze the
bank accounts linked to the rsf all
right let's bring in Hamid halafala who
is a Sudanese researcher and policy
analyst he's also a non-resident fellow
at The tahrira Institute for Middle East
policy he joins us from Cairo Hamid
we're more than a month into this
conflict are you able to form an
impression an accurate impression of who
has the upper hand at the moment
it's very difficult to tell who exactly
has the upper hand between the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Armed
Forces both of them keep on making
contradictory statements and I think if
you have learned anything by now uh they
clt4 as in this conflict started is that
both of them are not to be interested
and the words that they say are not to
be taken for for granted I've fled for
Tomb a few days ago up until I was there
when you go around the city on ground
you see that the rapid support forces
paramility has
higher presence than between outsources
and then to release our forces are
controlling the air in in so many ways
because they are conducting air rides
and and so on so I mean if I can jump in
this is something I wanted to ask you
the Army as you just pointed out has an
Air Force the rapid support forces
doesn't how is the rsf compensating for
this because this is normally a huge
advantage in any conflict when you have
air superiority
well in in an urban War uh that is
happening in this inside the city it's
uh limited what you can do with Air
Forces obviously uh so the rapid support
forces have also been uh shielding in
residential neighborhoods in in around
factories and so on is that the military
wouldn't obviously be very comfortable
uh selling although they have been
selling uh residential neighborhoods and
in the stadium neighborhoods a lot of
factories a lot of houses uh were uh
bombed down uh but I think there are
some strategy of locating in areas that
the military would obviously bomb but
not with maximum power uh has allowed
them to uh stay along that but also the
magnitude at the number of forces that
they have on ground uh it's they are
everywhere so it's it's it's difficult
for the Air Forces to uh like from all
of them
if neither side can defeat the other
then what's the next stage of this
conflict
well both the generals uh from a
personal perspective think that this is
a I lie for death kind of battle for
both of them each one of them is
determined to take the other one down uh
because it's basically a
struggle over power and so on but I
think uh they have they will come to
realize or have started realizing that
you know they cannot continue uh doing
this the way they are doing it either
both of them will lose everything uh so
I think there is an opportunity uh for
international mediation and for
international leverage to exert pleasure
on them to uh end the fight now
thank you very much for your insights
today